Welcome to human emotion psychology.
One third one.
I'm June Gruber,
a professor in the psychology department at Yale University.
Emotions are part of our everyday life.
Let's consider some of the emotions perhaps you experienced today.
Perhaps you felt irritated at your alarm clock,
waking up too early,
or maybe perhaps you were very excited and delighted by seeing your iPod
happening to play one of your most favorite songs as you were getting ready in
the morning.
Then again,
yeah,
perhaps you may have felt a pang of embarrassment when you tripped buying your
morning coffee in front of that same Barisa that you just can't seem to get the
courage to introduce yourself too.
Indeed,
emotions are part of our everyday life and in addition to these anecdotal
examples,
emotions serve really critical and important parts of who we are and what makes
us human.
Um,
for example,
one,
we know emotions motivate behaviors.
They really push us towards achieving our goals and help us shy away from
important dangers and threats to emotions are a kind of social glue.
There's social glue that not only bring us towards other people,
but they keep us in lifelong bonds with friends as well as partners.
And then finally,
emotions are also critical to our health.
We see that they underline not only our mental wellbeing,
but they actually facilitate and promote our physical wellbeing.
So emotions do a lot of amazing things for us.
But the question is,
how can this one thing called emotion do so many things for us and be such a
critical part of our everyday life.
How did emotions evolve to be bees?
Things for us in the first place?
And are they something that is unique to us as humans?
Or is it something that we see across all species?
Uh,
and finally,
in what way can we sort of take these emotions,
these things that serves so many functions for us,
that sort of color and underlie our everyday experiences?
How can we sort of take in,
harness them to build and lead more healthy lives?
So these are some of the questions that we're going to be looking at in this
course on human emotion.
And the hope is that you'll be able to understand some of these puzzles better.
And part of what's interesting and fascinating about understanding these puzzles
through the lens of human emotion is that you get exposed to a wide variety of
perspectives and techniques.
So you can see here by studying emotion,
um,
we're really sort of getting into fields not only in psychology but also in
neuroscience,
economics,
computer science,
and even art and music.
And I'm going show you today how the course will achieve these aims by using a
roadmap to guide you through the lecture.
So first I'll start with some core questions and topics that the course will
entertain.
Then we'll turn to logistics about how the course will be structured and operate
and we'll conclude with some takeaway questions that will summarize the key
points from today's lecture.
So let's begin with some sample questions and topics.
This course will address.
We'll start with perhaps the age old and puzzling question of what exactly is an
emotion.
Then we'll discuss to what extent emotions are evolutionarily evolved versus
more culturally constructed.
We'll also examine questions such as,
why do we laugh?
Why do we cry and is this healthy for us?
And then we'll want to understand,
you know,
how can we design studies that elicit and reliably measure emotional responses,
do culture and age change and transform our emotions,
who we are and what we feel.
And for many of us,
we often wonder,
can we,
by learning about emotions actually learned to read other people's emotions.
As you can see here,
yes,
our brain emotional.
So our brain was once solely thought to be devoted to rational thinking.
Can it also be devoted to emotional feelings and emotional thinking?
That is,
can we find certain parts of the brain and how it operates that gives rise to
our everyday emotional life.
Okay.
And although this is a class on human emotions,
we'll examine whether are not too distant monkey relatives as well as our canine
companions also have emotions.
And if they do have emotions,
how similar or different are they?
From our own?
Yeah.
And Ken emotion go awry.
That is can too much sadness as well as too much happiness can not give rise to
not only mental difficulties but also ways in which um,
emotions can really no longer serve the function that they were intended or
designed to serve.
Yeah.
And really what does sex have to do with it?
Another words,
you know,
how does sex play a role in our emotional life and our emotions?
Like desire,
really emotions in the first place.
Do our emotions make us more self conscious or self aware?
Emotions like shame and embarrassment.
Pride are some of the motions we'll talk about when we think about the issue of
whether or not emotions make us more self conscious.
Okay.
And does our wallet reflect our internal feelings?
In other words,
can money really buy happiness?
Is sleep a form of overnight therapy?
Here we'll examine the important role that researchers are finding that sleep
plays in restoring our emotional wellbeing all while we're laying in bed fast
asleep
and we'll conclude the course on a positive note regarding this important
question to all of us of how can we attain happiness?
A theme that as you can see here is a very popular and prevalent theme taking
flight,
especially in us culture.
Um,
we're more and more interested in understanding what makes us happy and are we
doing the right things to maximize and stay happy
in answering some of these questions.
Um,
we'll try to cover the main,
main course objectives and I think of three domains of eject objectives that I
hope you get out of this course in human emotion answering some of these
questions.
The first is really to expose you to a variety of current issues and theories of
emotion.
So different ways people have thought about and approach this topic.
Second,
um,
you'll get exposure to some of the most innovative and cutting edge scientific
methods and ways of thinking about measuring and studying emotion.
Okay.
And then third,
and this is perhaps the most important course objective,
is to instill a sense of curiosity and excitement in this new discipline.
Really,
human emotion has only taken flight in the past three decades.
So there's many questions as I bring up for you and we attempt to answer on this
course.
There's many,
perhaps even more unanswered questions.
So I hope that this curiosity and excitement will propel you further on in your
pursuit of understanding emotion better.
Yeah.
Next I want to turn to some of the core structure and logistics to get a feel of
how will this course operate.
Okay.
So there's different domains of logistics that are important and really unique
about this course.
I'm going to talk about the course website first,
then the videotape lectures,
what you're watching right now,
discussion sections and expert interviews.
So I'm just going to touch base first on the course website.
So here's an example of the course website.
You can see here on human emotion psychology one 31 taught by myself,
professor June grouper.
Um,
this website will have access not only to a calendar that will lay out all of
the different readings and timeline,
but it will also have the requirements for the course materials that you can
download,
a including handouts,
slides and other related materials.
It'll have a website,
have links of interest,
sort of looking at emotion and the broader pop culture and media,
um,
as well as contact information as well.
So this will be your kind of go to resource for a lot of important materials,
uh,
and guidelines that you'll be covering in the course.
Okay.
Next one really unique aspect of this course that may not be common props.
It's the first time you've taken a course as such,
our videotape lectures.
So as you can see here and what you've been seeing today in the course is that,
um,
all of these lectures will be videotaped for you to watch at your own
convenience,
so at a time and place that works for you.
Okay.
Third are the discussion sections.
So you will have live discussion sections that will look something like this
where you'll be engaging in discussion with your other class members at the
bottom here,
um,
as well as your instructor or teaching assistant for the course.
Um,
these will be meeting regularly and you'll be able to engage in interactive
exercises with your teacher as well as classmates as well as feel free to ask
questions in this virtual discussion section.
Environments.
Yeah.
And then finally,
and perhaps one of the most exciting pieces for me personally to share with you
in this course are the expert interviews.
So this is what's called the experts and emotion interview series.
And here you're going to have the opportunity to hear conversations with
visionary figures in the study of human emotion.
And we'll have approximately one of these expert interviews that will nicely map
onto the lecture component and content that you'll have covered that day.
So not only will you get to read about emotion,
watch the online video tape lectures,
discuss them with your classmates in section,
but also get to hear some of the leaders in the field talk about what they think
are the most important aspects of studying emotion and where they see the face
of the future headed.
They'll look something like this.
So it will include a videotape conversation between an emotion expert such as on
the left with me,
your professor for the course on the rights.
Yeah.
And to give you a sneak peak,
here's a sample of some of the experts that you're going to have a chance to
hear,
speak about emotion as part of these expert interviews for the course.
Okay.
And I want to conclude today with the takeaway questions.
So here I'm going to cover three main points that I'd like to make sure that you
got while watching this video tape lecture.
And I'll have take home questions at the end of every lecture module to assure
that the main points that I hope were conveyed,
we're clearly,
um,
you know,
transmitted to you and that you know what you need to know.
So the three takeaway questions for this first lecture today include one,
what kinds of sample questions will you be able to answer by taking this course?
Okay.
To what are the three unique video components of this course?
What makes this course unique as compared to more traditional classroom
environment?
Uh,
settings.
Okay.
And then three,
and this is a really important logistical point,
I hope everyone knows where can you go to find the relevant course materials,
assignment,
due dates and associated readings.
So with that,
I want to welcome you to human emotion.
Um,
and here are some of the credits for the images discuss today in our slides.